uh you're obviously a big hip-hop guy
give me your top five favorite albums of
all time I don't I won't go um let me go
people okay give me your top five
because you got Tupac on your hand yeah
I got Tupac and Nipsey on my head I'm
gonna take Tupac and and and Biggie out
of it okay that's fair for me those are
my two all-time favorites outside of
that and that's and anybody can say
those two who do I listen to the most I
listen to Jay-Z
I listened to to Wayne
I listen to Drake
I listen to nipsy
it was my fifth gonna be
it's probably gonna be a tie between
like Rick Ross and Snoop that's fair
that's fair yeah that's not a bad five
you [ __ ] with any of the younger [ __ ]
because obviously there's
um my kids like I like little baby right
I saw that there was a little there let
me ask you because you're a hip-hop head
there was a debate obviously I know
where I stand but they said uh the
little Wayne a little baby thing it's
Lil Wayne I don't even think it's close
it's not even close it's like like let's
relax it's like everybody needs to relax
with all due respect all due respect I
love little baby and I love my turn it's
a great album everyone needs to [ __ ]
relax hey Weezy like listen come on
everyone needs to [ __ ] relax I saw
that tweet going viral I'm like guys
everyone needs to [ __ ] relax for a
second I didn't even comment on it just
because I knew and I'm very proud and
I'm very critical of little Wayne yeah
everyone needs to [ __ ] relax they're
not in the same [ __ ] conversation
yeah people these Twitter people are
[ __ ] insane man I'll just be staying
in my like I said if I hear it out and
about or you know in the in the content
space out here and my kids are telling
me about it but most of the time I'll be
staying on my own you know I mean the
the people I listed I'd be kind of
saying to them like heavy on that huge
just huge fan of nip got a chance to
meet nip when um
man when I first came to Lakers over
2000s and my brothers always put me on
music